echo fox is on fire and i don't mean
that in the good way
the sale of their LCS lot has fallen
through amit rosada the shareholder who
said some racist stuff is still with the
company and now he's alleging that rick
fox destroyed the org
meanwhile rick fox is saying that rise
audit is a con man and he's lying to
echo fox fan
all right let's do a quick recap because
this [ __ ] is crazy echo fox shareholder
ama try SATA used racist language in an
email to Jace Hall riot didn't like that
and echo Fox was put in the position
where they had to either get rid of Roy
SATA or sell their LCS lot they couldn't
get rid of rosada so they started the
sale process Kroenke sports
entertainment one of the largest sports
ownership groups in the world who own
the overwatch leagues la gladiators
among other major sports teams offered
to buy echo Fox's LCS slot 4:30 point
two five million dollars and then [ __ ]
started to fall apart on Friday August
9th echo fox sent out a press release
stating that quote due to circumstances
unrelated to echo fox Kroenke sports
entertainment was unable to me try games
requirements for acquiring echo fox LCS
lot with that said echo fox retains the
slot rights not as lawyers told me that
that was because KSC's the esports arm
was sued by their business partner
Robert Moores the CEO of sentinels the
company that runs the LA gladiators for
Kroenke in case you're wondering what's
happening over there according to a
report from ESPN jacob wolf more alleged
that the coffee is trying to buy the
echo fox LCS lot violated a verbal
agreement they had about expansion into
esports since then they've settled the
suit but will be pursuing the echo fox
LCS lot anymore basically it's a mess
and either KFC pulled out because of the
lawsuit or riot saw the lawsuit and
wouldn't let k SC into the LCS until it
got resolved so now riot controls the
sale of the LCS slot but there are a ton
of allegations about how we even got
here
I talked with AMA tri sada on the phone
for an hour and he gave me his side of
the story now I want to preface this by
saying that I also got a long statement
from Rick Fox
which we'll get into later in the video
but know that thoughts categorically
denies everything that rise honest says
and go so far as to call him a con man
I also want to preface where he's on a
statements by saying that he owned up to
using racist language and threatening
language in his communications with Jace
Hall and Rick Fox as has been alleged
several times he even admitted to being
in the wrong at least when it came to
the incident with Jace Hall Wright made
their statement rosada admitted to it
and no one's really calling what he said
into question anymore instead rise out
of spent most of our interview alleging
that Rick Fox is millions of dollars in
debt and has
rude over echovox now I have a statement
from Rick Fox where he denies all of
this but again I'm gonna get to it after
we go through the timeline so let's
start from the beginning again
way back in 2015 after Rick Fox decided
to get into eSports rosada says that he
and Cooley Jones each invested a million
dollars into echo Fox half a million
each to buy the LCS lot and another half
a million each to funteam operations
you'll notice that he didn't mention
Rick Fox in that funding see the way
that rides odda tells it Rick Fox didn't
have any financial stake in echo Fox
when it was founded and continued not to
have any until October 2018 the way
rides on it tells it Rick Fox was given
a small token amount of shares an echo
box and those shares were quickly
diluted after a funding round
really according to rosada Rick Fox was
mostly the company's brand ambassador
and if all this is true I'm sure you'll
agree that's not what we were all led to
believe about Rick Fox's relationship
with echo Fox
here's the thing though in a recent
interview with optic gaming CEO Hector
Hector Rodriguez Rick Fox said that none
of that is true he says he spent his own
money on the company just like every
other investor this is another another
lie that's out there and I've never put
a dollar into echo fox I [ __ ] I was
you know we bought the slot I put my
money in just like the other four people
yeah
the slot den was purchased by by another
entity when he became the entity that
raised every amazed everyone was out and
you went to work though oh I spent my
own dollars I bought a plane tickets
equipment yeah I got a receipts like all
this stuff never I never asked to be
reimbursed Yeah right look like
thousands in a lot of money jumping
forward a few years according to Ray
SATA and documents that he and his legal
team sent to us in December 2017 echo
Fox borrowed 2.5 million dollars from
Twin Galaxies in order to pay for the
franchise LCS law now if you don't know
what Twin Galaxies is there a company
run by Jace Hall that handles
competitive video game records they were
also a major part of the failed h1z1
League which shuddered after just half a
season last year according to those same
documents Becka Fox continued to borrow
another 2.5 million dollars in Twin
Galaxies throughout 2018
though it didn't tell us exactly what
those funds were for these loans were
allegedly secured by Echo Fox's access
which means that if they defaulted on
the loan the lender Twin Galaxies would
take control of Echo Fox's teams their
offices anything that they owned really
by summer 20
18 rise Auto alleges that Twin Galaxies
ran out of buns and went to their
investors including rise oughtta and
borrowed another three million dollars
secured by there alone to echo bombs
that meant that if Twin Galaxies
couldn't pay their three million dollar
debt back the investors would take
control of echo foxes alone and could
collect on it whenever this is super
complicated but in simple terms echo fox
owed five million dollars to Twin
Galaxies Twin Galaxies owed three
million dollars to their investors
including AMA cries odda when Twin
Galaxies went bankrupt the investors
including rosada took control of the
five million dollar debt that echo fox
had now here's where things get weird
rise odd alleges that in June 2018 he
and Rick Fox had a discussion that
involved Rick Fox saying he wanted to
get out of echovox rise out a census
would appear to be texts between him and
Rick Fox in which rosada recommends that
Fox raise money to buy rise out a share
of the company or else rosada would have
to sell his share to a guy named
Stratton sklavos another major
shareholder in Echo fall in these texts
Fox responds by saying that if sklavos
gain more control the company Fox would
have to leave entirely right auto refers
to this as evidence that Rick Fox wanted
out of echo fox though it seems to me at
least from reading these that Fox only
wanted out if sklavos gain more control
anyway moving on to October 4 the
ownership transfer actually happened
according to documents that rise out of
sent us Rick Fox and Kelly Jones formed
a company called axon which they used to
buy the ownership share of echo fox from
rosada for five million dollars each the
documents say they were required to pay
1 million dollars as deposit by October
26 2018 and other 4 million by January
5th 2019 and the remaining 5 million
dollars by June 1st 2019 now I want to
salt the timeline to note that Rick Fox
corroborates certain parts of this story
in his interview with Richard Lewis Fox
says that quote about eight months ago
he purchased a controlling interest in
Echo Falls I purchased the controlling
interest was back from one of the
original co-founders and it was at that
point that I did that because of a
protective desire to not only protect
the brand to protect the rest of the
limited partners he also says that once
this happened he quote pulled back the
curtain to a mess he reiterated this in
his hex
even going so far as to say that the
people who are running the company at
the time allegedly we're driving echo
Fox to bankruptcy I spent I spent my
more money a lot of money to buy people
out of control that were threatened to
bankrupt the company people don't know
this story they were threatened to
bankrupt the company in the summer of
2018 and I had to put more of my money
into the company to get it away from
people that were going to drive it off
the cliff and when I got it in my hands
the state it was in I've seen cars
totaled that looked better than this all
right so let's stroll back here for a
second the way that Rick Fox tells this
part of the story is that not only did
he put his own money in TECO Fox he also
spent a lot of his personal time working
for and helping the org then after one
split of the ALCS the ownership group
approached Rick Fox and asked him to
step aside from operations so a more
experienced business person could take
over then Jace Hall came in as CEO
followed by Stratton's clavos who was
also brought in to run the company at
some point during all this Fox says he
grew suspicious and so he bought control
of the company back and allegedly
discovered a financial disaster on his
hands so Fox says that once he took
control the org had to start making
difficult financial decisions to survive
like cutting players and staff Fox also
says in his interview with Richard Lewis
that he made the first payment to rosada
on his purchase which surprised odd as
documents also corroborated here is
where the stories diverged again so rise
out of legends the back in December 2018
echo Fox and Twin Galaxies both ran out
of money do you remember what that means
well amended Twin Galaxies defaulted on
their debt which meant that the
investors including rosada gained
control of Echo Foxes alone all of a
sudden echo Fox owed five million
dollars to AMA try SATA and other
shareholders rosada says that there was
a mutual agreement to turn Echo Fox's
debt into senior preferred equity which
basically means that anybody who was
owed money by echo fox ought to turn
their debt into ownership share of echo
fox and they got first crack at any new
money that went into the company until
that debt was paid meanwhile according
to Rick Fox this only happened after
rosada put a metaphorical guns
we were in the process of trying to
raise capital at the same time you know
we were forced to figure out how to keep
this thing afloat Xbox Xbox negotiated
with me to convert my debt to equity it
was not just my debt everyone says it
was just Hobbit Amin Amin
it was Amin and others and an additional
three million dollars or four million
dollars of new money that came in on top
of on top of my money
and we'll all flow that in there and
that's how the company's been operating
for the last year you can choose to
believe either one the stories are
actually pretty similar it's just the
tone that changes at the end of the day
both seem to agree that it was the right
move for the company at the time since
it allowed echo fox to get out of debt
and allow the business people to get the
company back in order alright so here's
another place where the stories don't
quite line up rise I'll alleges that in
late January 2019 Fox wanted out of echo
Fox once again he sent us emails between
himself and a lawyer Greg Nelson who
says that Fox wanted to get out of echo
thoughts to work for Twin Galaxies this
email chain also includes what Fox
alleges was rosada threatening him and
his family
now rosada says that it was merely a
threat of a lawsuit not a threat of
violence which I suppose is definitely
one way to read this email Greg
frankly I'm not retraining if you are
saying he is holding assisting with an
exit or whatever his fiduciary duty is
you can frankly go [ __ ] yourself
you are one of the most unethical and
unprofessional people I've ever met no
deal on anything and if Rick does not do
his duties I'll personally [ __ ] him and
his family for the rest of my life in
any way possible
don't ever threaten me with him not
assistant I'm going to sue him and you
over this once again this doesn't make
rise out it look like a paragon of good
manners or anything but I mean he does
threaten a lawsuit following this in
April rosada sent an email to Jace Hall
that included racist language once again
that part is not in question the email
then made its way to the public after
portion of it were published by Richard
Lewis on Kickstarter in May that email
triggered an investigation into echo Fox
by Riot Games which according to emails
that rise out of sent us found four
material breaches in echo Fox's
agreement with Ryan the first was
failure to obtain consent for having
over a million dollars in debt
pretty self-explanatory the second was
theory to maintain at least five million
dollars in illiquid reserves the third
was a failure to obtain riots consent
for having over 10% of new equity in the
company which happened with the senior
preferred equity that rosada gained when
he and others took control of echo Fox's
debt and the fourth the one we already
knew about was Rises racist language in
his communications with Jace Hall at
this riah requested that Ahmet rosada be
removed from the company presumably
because it solved the ladder to material
breaches now there are a lot of
allegations about what happened with
that and I'm still trying to sort them
all out and corroborate them until we
have a video explaining everything that
happened here we can simply say that it
didn't work out and riot required the
slot be sold
meanwhile in June Rhys Auto alleges that
Fox refused to pay the rest of the money
he owed rosada for that purchase of a
controlling share of Eko Fox and Fox was
sued for that rosada sent over court
documents that show that a company
called 11 stones is suing rick fox in
miami for 2.5 million dollars plus the
cost of the lawsuit we asked Rick Fox
for a statement on all of rosado's
allegations and this is what he had to
say there is literally no limit to what
amit rosada will make up and say in his
Questacon money out of investors and to
hurt me and my family so what is the
point of addressing anything he says
from this point on his credibility is
now zero at this point and my responses
to his further lying just bring him more
attention which will in turn continue to
motivate him to add more lies to his big
steaming pile vomit rosada is currently
paying a team of people to spread his
lies and spread and damage my reputation
he has a PR company lawyers himself and
others all coordinating their daily
attack on me and the truths I have
spoken
vomit hopes to confuse the public and
hide his malfeasance and fraud in the
disarray i'ma try SATA has expressed on
many occasions that he thinks the gaming
community is stupid and holds it in very
low regard he has fake paid Twitter
accounts trying to bash me all the time
and support his paid for self
aggrandizing puff-piece article it's all
very easy to spot and the community has
already busted him a few times doing
this on it also attempts to drag any
news site he can into his web of lies
and the ones that refused he threatens
to sue them I already know he's
threatened some people and sites with
lawsuits and legal notices to quiet them
down he will continue to do this bully
behavior it is nothing new
vomit rosada is attempted
to use your newscast to push his lies
and agenda against me he wants you to
help him create more fake
counter-argument out there that is the
purpose of his interview with you
nothing more there's a lot more to Fox's
statement including a link to a lawsuit
in which former business partners of
Rosetta's are suing him for wronging
them through quote deceptive schemes and
they're alleging he participated in
frauds threats and a smear campaign
against I'm still working my way through
this lawsuit but you can be sure once
I've made sense of it we'll have another
video for you about that as well Fox
points to the lawsuit and alleges that
rosada has a pattern of behavior that
he's doing the same thing to Fox now
that he allegedly did to his former
business partners he goes on to call
rosada a con man and ends a statement
like this quote I have no such record or
pattern of the kind of behavior I may
try sada demonstrates I'm in eSports
because I love my son the community and
the culture i'ma try SATA has
demonstrated that he is here to exploit
me and everyone else he can get his
hands on this is what he has a proven
pattern of doing I hope you don't fall
for his con so you can believe what he
tells you or not
it's up to you and the audience I'm
through directly responding to anything
he says it's a waste of time he's not
important to me end quote
jumping ahead to last week ride
announced that they'll be taking over
the sale process for Echo Fox is LCS lot
but they'll be giving most of the
proceeds from that sale to echo Fox from
what I've been told by raised auda and
his legal team it wasn't an option that
most of echo Fox as shareholders wanted
meanwhile Rick Fox has said in both his
interview with Richard Lewis and hex
that it was an option he was in favor of
on one hand it's an open sale and riot
gets to pick the best partner on the
other riot doesn't have to pick the
highest bidder which might mean less
money for echo fox shareholders and that
brings us to today where we have two
sides of the story on one side ama tries
auda who has presented a ton of
documents that support his side of the
story but clearly has an axe to grind in
this situation meanwhile on the other
side we have Rick Fox who's
categorically denying everything that
Rice auto says and says that he's trying
to trick you the echo fox fans and the
eyes of the law one person is gonna be
right here and one person is gonna be
wrong
I really cannot tell you who that's
going to be because well I'm not a US
judge what I can do for you is present
you both sides and hopefully we can come
closer to the truth for now make up your
own mind but you can be sure that
we'll have more videos for you about
this in the days to come thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification Bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]